ici sur le site de grignon nous avons
les témoins de l'arrivée de la mer à
environ dans le sud du bassin de paris à
environ 46 millions d'années c'est ce
que l'on peut observer dans cette
carrière le griot les témoins d'une
époque où la mer arrivait jusqu'à paris
ce sont ces fossiles de mollusques ou
ressent nautile et autres animaux marins
aujourd'hui présents des régions
tropicales plus de 800 espèces
différentes réunies dans une zone de
plus de 33 hectares à grignon on va
pouvoir n'est trouvée par gros par
millions à partir du moment où tamise
on regarde le sol suffit de regarder le
sol sol est pétri de coquillages qui
sont d'une conservation exceptionnel si
on se place à l'échelle mondiale et bien
on a une faune qui est quasiment parmi
les plus riches du monde
au niveau de la paléo biodiversité un
gisement étudié depuis le xviiie siècle
pour préserver ce trésor historique et
scientifique
l'état a pris un arrêté de protection du
patrimoine géologique pour cette zone et
pour une autre de 9 ha ha ben une
première en france
ce site qui était qui était au seinde
agroparistech donc un domaine de l'état
on a entendu que ce site talent est mis
en vente
donc un imprimé donc ce site on pensait
protégée depuis plus de 20 depuis qu'on
connaît en fait l'existence du
patrimoine géologique était menacée
puisque ça allait être vendu à un privé
grâce à l'action de la direction
régionale de l'environnement et de
l'énergie et à la commission régionale
du patrimoine géologique les gisements
sont désormais hors de danger
les scientifiques du monde entier
pourront continuer à percer tous leurs
secrets